The code for this course lives in a Git
repository, hosted on GitHub.com.
While you don't really need to know
anything about Git or GitHub for
this course.
I wanted to explain a bit, so that Git
doesn't seem like some scary black box.
A Git Repository, or repo, is just
a folder full of stuff, usually code.
As well as a history of
snapshots of that code.
These snapshots are knows as commits.
If this repository is sitting
on a server somewhere,
it become super easy for a bunch of
people to all talk to the repository.
Potentially, all making
changes at the same time
in such a way that no ones steps on
each others toes with their changes.
The very, very short version,
is that you clone a repository.
You make some changes
to your local files.
You commit those files to
your local repository.
Merge in any changes that anyone
else has made in the meantime.
And then push your version back
up to the main repository.
Git is what's called a version control
system, and it makes creating software
projects, like the code for
this course, super, super easy.
If you're interested in learning more,
Udacity actually has a whole
course on Git, which you can
find at udacity.com/ud775, or
by following the link down
in the instructor notes.
Bookmark it and check it out later.
Git is a crazy useful tool.
Anyway, at Udacity,
we use a service called GitHub
to host our Git repositories.
The code we're going to share with you
has actually been on GitHub the entire
time we've been working on this course.
It's just that we flipped a switch
to make the repository public
when the course went live.
That also means that all the messy
history from when this course was in
development is still in there.
Feel free to poke around and find all
the embarrassing commit messages.
Also, to you GitHub masters out there,
if you find errors in the course code,
pull requests are gratefully accepted.